hi there this is Steve Kaufman today I
want to talk about what some of the
specialists in language teaching
referred to as fossilization and it's
kind of a continuation of the previous
video that I did about the whole subject
of getting frustrated in our language
learning the language specialists like
to talk about fossilization a term that
they invented to refer to the situation
where people reach a certain level in
their language ability and they don't
improve now first of all let me say that
I'm not a fan I've mentioned this before
of all these specialist terms in
language teaching I don't like the term
fossilization you know if fossils to me
are I guess forms of life that died and
were you know submerged under layers and
layers of rock or whatever and they're
vestiges of life that existed you know
millions of years ago or hundreds of
thousands of years ago I don't see the
connection with with language money what
happens is people reach a plateau and I
must prefer the word Plateau
I just digress here a lot of these terms
that are used by the language specially
specialist really annoy me like the term
inter language which is used to refer to
the fact that when we're learning
another language we're very much
influenced by our first language so
we're kind of in between languages well
at what point do I go from speaking
inter language to speaking you know
Russian or Czech or Spanish or whatever
other language that I that I'm learning
I just think these are sort of a
continuum we never speak the second
language quite as well as our first
language but we are speaking that
language we're not speaking inter
language I also don't like such terms as
language acts you know I like to refer
to just using the language listening
reading speaking the term in language
acts doesn't add anything so there's a
lot of these terms like register you
know there's a register for this a
register for that so people become
self-conscious we had a person at link
telling us that they were being asked to
identify the register
in their language study it doesn't
matter you yeah initially I think you
speak of sort of a neutral level of the
language and as you progress you become
quite capable of naturally and
subconsciously adjusting the tone of
your language to suit the situation
however that's digressing let's get back
to the subject of fossilization and
we've all met people you know I have a
gardener here who's Vietnamese he's he
understands he jokes in English but his
English has reached a lover level where
it's not going to improve what do we do
when it when it reaches that level and
what causes it well I'm not a specialist
I haven't studied I haven't done you
know peer-reviewed Studies on the
subject but my feeling is that people
who sort of don't progress beyond a
certain level very often are actually
satisfied with that level it works for
them they're not tremendously motivated
to take it to another level so I think
that's a lot of the cases for my
Vietnamese gardener he communicates
quite comfortably has a heavy accent
some people may find him difficult to
understand but he gets through his day
he manages to deal with with people and
not a problem I had a Swiss banker
working you know providing services to
me who's smoking is actually better than
most native speakers but he had the bed
do have Biswas accent didn't Islam so is
he fossilized I don't know that's how he
speaks he communicates extremely
effectively he probably isn't interested
in changing his Swiss accent it doesn't
it's not gonna give him anything people
like him for what he is
so however there are perhaps some people
who feel they've reached a plateau and
would like to get better in fact in many
cases those people are getting better
because very often we don't realize how
we are gradually and ever so you know
almost imperceptibly improving in the
language but where we have a person who
is genuinely stuck and genuinely wants
to improve and feels that they are stuck
in a rut what can we do well I think
that that a large part of language
learning is emotional
so if you like that culture of the
language which is not a given you may
not or if you like at least some aspects
of the culture we rarely do we like
everything about a culture we like some
things you know I enjoy many aspects of
Japanese culture I find that spending an
evening watching a noh performance is a
no-no for me unless I'm obliged to go
there I've done it a couple of times and
that's enough however there's so many
other aspects of Japanese culture that I
really like so I I can feel a strong
affinity for certain aspects of Japanese
culture I love listening to Japanese
audiobooks I love the sort of quiet
elegance in the somewhat indirect way in
which things are expressed in many
situations in Japanese and the same is
true for every language there are things
that I like there are forms of the
language that I like there are people
that I like and if you can listen to
something that you like it might be
music it might be songs it might be
television programs movies in my case it
was the in Chinese for example these
young young comic dialogues which were
to me like music now I'm doing my check
I can't understand much of the audiobook
of the good soldier Shrake but I love
the professional mmm narration of the
story the story storyteller is so much
more engaging than listening to the news
on you know radio prog so you have to
find things that you like that can
engage you emotionally it might be a
friend as I say and if you have that and
if you are willing to put in the time
and you are genuinely becoming if you
become attached to this aspect of the
language to the sound of the language to
the culture I think you can improve if
you want to if you have this affinity
for this emotional attachment for and
you put in the time now I mean you all
remember the golden Trinity of language
learning which Kelly I have mentioned in
many of my videos attitude time with the
language and the ability to notice so
the attitude is that sense of
wanting to wanting to improve affinity
liking finding things that you
particularly like to read or listen to
or watch on TV movies whatever so that's
one aspect of it it's the attitude the
determination and the desire and the
sense of affinity and affection the
second is the time you have to put in
the time if you want to improve very
often people who have this achieved this
what they call a level of fossilization
very often are immigrants who early on
have to sort of come up with a sort of a
self defense level of the language
because they have to work in the
language and never really have pushed
themselves beyond that so you have to
them if you want to get beyond that you
have to put some time into deliberately
improving your language whether it be
increasing your vocabulary or working on
your pronunciation or working on some of
the structures the third thing you have
to do is you have to develop the ability
to notice so you have to I like to
underline words and phrases so that then
I hear them I noticed them or certain
structures that I know that I have
trouble with sometimes listening to
yourself and then listening to a native
speaker to pick up the differences will
help you notice sometimes leafing
through a grammar book will help you
notice but whatever it is the person who
has fossilised have to has to put some
effort into noticing where they can
improve where the gaps are whether it be
in pronunciation or usage or in
vocabulary so again it's the golden
Trinity I think if a person has the
right attitude it has an affinity for
the language wants to improve if they
put the time in and if they do these
things that are going to help them
notice things in the language then
fossilization is not unavoidable
condition
I don't believe it's not like a fossil
that has been you know compressed and
it's under X layers of rock or whatever
that's been lying there for half a
million years that fossil is not gonna
change but there is no one who speaks a
language and who's feels that they
reached the plateau and who can't change
I don't believe I think it's a matter of
wanting to and as I say the golden
Trinity
properly applied will enable the person
to all of a sudden the fossil comes to
life and they can you know improve the
language skills so there's my take on
fossilization including the usual
gratuitous kick at the formal language
teaching industry and all of its
buzzwords which I'm sure will bring a
bit of a you know a counter from the
people who enjoy doing that and all the
more power to them I have my slant on
things and and they have a different
slant and and you know vive la
différence thank you for listening bye
for now